[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
está con nosotros en el estudio Marc con
una muy buena noticia porque tenemos
Premio Nobel de medicina y fisiología
Así es Raúl muy buenos días una noticia
que llegó de hecho apenas estábamos
llegando también nosotros a la redacción
que llevamos explicando desde el día de
hoy hoy vamos a entrar realmente en
detalle como decíamos no el premiado ha
sido esvante pavo es una genetista un
científico de 67 años nacido en
estocolmo Suecia a pocos kilómetros
desde derecho anunciaron desde donde
anunciaron Ah Pues esta premiación este
galardón que recibió es un genetista que
dedicó toda su vida a estudiar la
información genética de nuestros
antepasados prehistóricos no y de hecho
se le considera el padre de una nueva
disciplina la paleogenética es decir
este estudio genético de todas las
poblaciones prehistóricas no en 2010
logró secuenciar el primer ADN
neardental gracias a unas nuevas
técnicas que ahora vamos a explicar
también en más detalle y de hecho fueron
gracias a estas técnicas él logró
encontrar una nueva especie de humano
los denisovanos no a través de una
pequeño hueso que se encontró en una
cueva de Siberia se cueció ese ADN y
encontró una nueva especie de homínidos
que no se sabía que existía en la década
de los 90 además pues fundó el Instituto
Max planck de antropología evolutiva uno
de los centros de referencia de todo lo
que se considera investigación
científica de la evolución donde todavía
a día de hoy trabaja Cuáles son más los
principales hallazgos de Cervantes pago
claro pues es que antes de su
intervención de que empezara a
investigar no el único canal que
teníamos para mirar hacia el pasado
hacia nuestros antepasados prehistóricos
eran los huesos por ejemplo los dientes
restos arqueológicos como la ropa no la
datación de carbono también que son
herramientas que pues proporcionan mucha
información y a día de hoy Todavía
siguen siendo muy importantes para
explicar lo que la genética no explica
pero desde que él empezó a estudiar
estos ADN esto proporciona una cantidad
de información que parece como si los
científicos que estudian la prehisto los
antropólogos los arqueólogos se les
hubieran de repente desempañado las
gafas que hubieran podido ver con mucho
más detalle una cantidad de información
que antes pues no teníamos acceso nunca
se había conseguido descifrar un ADN tan
Antiguo y pues gracias a esta
información una de las respuestas que
tenemos por ejemplo en qué nos parecemos
y en qué nos diferenciamos a nuestros
antepasados además por ejemplo Gracias
como decíamos también antes a su
secuenciación del ADN podemos saber que
los neardentales y los Homo Sapiens se
reprodujeron y se mezclaron de una forma
relativamente sistemática hasta el punto
de que a día de hoy todavía tenemos un 1
o 2% algunos dicen que hasta 4% de ADN
neardental y que lo mismo ocurrió con
los denisovanos no este 16% que todavía
tienen poblaciones asiáticas y
euroasiáticas los neardentales y los
Homo Sapiens Pues el último ancestro
común fue alrededor de los del millón de
años más o menos y pues los Homo Sapiens
que surgieron de África y que fueron
migrando hacia Europa en esta migración
fue empezó esa mezcla Esto no se podría
haber sabido estas migraciones con tanta
precisión si no tuviéramos toda esta
información genética que nos dio las
investigaciones de este científico bueno
mar Pero digamos Cómo consiguió el
recuperar la información genética tan
tan antigua claro estamos hablando de un
ADN de decenas de miles de años de
antigüedad no hay muchas veces esta
información genética está comprometida
después de que pase tanto tiempo está
degradada está cortada como a pedacitos
o puede quedar contaminada por bacterias
o por otros elementos externos Entonces
es lo que decidió fue en vez de buscar
en el ADN del núcleo de la célula que es
nuestro ADN completo busco en el ADN
mitocondrial las mitocondrias son una
parte que está en el núcleo Perdón en el
núcleo dentro de la célula pero fuera
del núcleo esta parte verde que vemos en
el gráfico y son como las centrales
energéticas digamos de las células a que
hacen el metabolismo allí hay una parte
del ADN hay menos que en el núcleo solo
es la parte digamos que heredamos desde
la vía materna Pero hay muchas más
mitocondrias entonces
aumentaba la probabilidad de que pudiera
encontrar ADN mitocondrial en buen
estado entonces Gracias por ejemplo a
tener esta idea y también a desarrollar
nuevos algoritmos y nuevas técnicas y
también de rodearse con un equipo pues
muy potente porque sabemos que un hombre
solo nunca va a descubrir nada logró por
ejemplo Esa primera secuencia de un ADN
neardental una técnica que además ahora
se ha replicado a Pues a muchas más
escalas han hecho muchas más secuencias
y de hecho hemos recuperado pues como
hablaba él el momento de ese anuncio
hace más de 10 años escuchamos
el neardental es nuestro pariente más
cercano hasta ahora solo nos podíamos
comparar con los chimpancés que son
parientes bastante lejanos Hoy podemos
decir que hay cambios en nuestro genoma
que son totalmente únicos a los humanos
modernos y es una lista interesante de
cambios porque allí se esconden cosas
que tienen que ver con aspectos como
desarrollar una cultura desarrollar
tecnología o colonizar el planeta entero
mar ahora le preguntó las implicaciones
que tienen estos hallazgos en nuestro
día a día en la actualidad claro una
pregunta podemos dejar de hacer porque
es muy bonito hablar de esas respuestas
a la preguntas como Quiénes somos que
nos hace únicamente Humanos a las cuales
todas estas investigaciones han
contribuido pero es que también pasan
cosas a nivel cotidiano por ejemplo
alrededor de la salud por eso también
recibe el premio Nobel de medicina y
fisiología no por ejemplo sabemos que
partes de este ADN que heredamos de los
neardentales sobre todo de nuevo las
poblaciones europeas tienen que ver con
la respuesta inmune este estudio con el
covid 19 no había algunos genes que por
ejemplo aumentaban el riesgo de tener
grave mientras que había otros genes
también pues heredados de la del ADN
neardental que en cambio nos protegían
un poco no entonces pues nada bueno ni
nada malo no a veces también se dice que
no esta herencia neardental parece que
tenga como connotaciones negativas y no
es así también se sabe que estas partes
genéticas tienen que ver a veces con la
esquizofrenia con la posibilidad de
desarrollar artritis y también con la
posibilidad de tener niveles altos de
colesterol entonces bueno tener todo
este mapa no nos sirve mucho para
entender Qué implicaciones tienen
nuestra salud para poder prever también
que pues qué problemas podemos tener en
adelante y de hecho también en el caso
de los denisovanos de esta otra especie
que él mismo descubrió se sabe que hay
un gen que permite vivir Pues a gran
altura mucho mejor y que de hecho gran
parte de la población tibetana y de los
sherpas de hoy en día todavía tienen y
explica por ejemplo Por qué pueden vivir
con mucho más facilidad que el resto de
nosotros a esas grandes alturas entonces
a ese nivel llegan sus descubrimientos
mar Muchísimas gracias como siempre por
esta secciones de salud especial que ya
se entregó como dijimos el premio Nobel
de fisiología y también de medicina
Gracias mar Hasta mañana Muchas gracias
a ti